dr. 0621 I have John Luke I told in the
queue up the live stream with you and
Rob which part yeah which part um I
don't know jean-luc if you have
something up right now that you want to
roll we can throw that up just to give
people a sense of what how yeah cos is 0
roll down beautiful footage yeah it'll
roll a second what what I'm talking
until its role in Arras ski here we go
all right here we go yeah Sippie going
to me what's going on so this is a game
about hardcore criminals back to have
each other look the opposite series is
something that's been like bubbling
under the surface for years and people
really love it and it seems like every
game that passes that crab doesn't
really grow for whatever reason it may
be people have a hard time jumping in
but yeah because 0 is the perfect entry
point because it is a prequel to the
original game so you don't need to know
anything about the characters maybe if
you do you'll appreciate the story more
but really this is a good excuse to
finally play ah kiza if you've been
wondering about it and this is the first
one I've finished and I the games that
play before like the same thing as
present here where you have this
juxtaposition between very serious
storytelling about criminals trying to
you know work their way through the
ranks right but also be loyal and good
friends to the people that matter to
them but also try to figure out like do
they really matter to me are they my
good friend so there's a lot of sort of
like betrayal and stuff that happens
like that but then when you aren't
engaged with the story you are doing one
of two things you are either fighting
people which is not one of the game
strong suits it has this sort of very
simple Arkady beat-'em-up saying that
would feel oh god here we go yeah
beat-'em-up component that feels like it
belongs like a late 90s early 3d arcade
game all right don't get you realize it
or porn about to come up all right
firing that in a little way possible
very literal way and then you have these
other pursuits where you can go around
town and you can play arcade games you
can
go out to restaurants you can do karaoke
you can disco dance you can watch
essentially pull right up close to this
old CRT V just chilling with your
ashtray in your box issues and no shame
yes is going to come kick in the studio
door right now what is this exercise
video what are you talking about she's a
lot of exercise he's on an exercise ball
I can't let go anyway hey wait look away
from this mess keep going with what
you're saying provided you give it you
gave it seemed an 8 out of 10 yeah so
you were saying it's just weird blend of
melodrama and just like taking a selfie
not serious Curtis comedy right so like
if you have these weird things or like
okay yeah this is uncomfortable and
strange but okay yeah but it's bad thank
you you think they'll believe you but if
it's the pursuits are not just like
wacky things like softcore porn right
yeah you also you get to meet the
citizens in these recreations of cities
in Japan this case would be a part of
Tokyo and a part of Osaka and these
random citizens need help with certain
things right like one girl is sort of
like hey you I've been lying to my dad
about having a boyfriend you happen to
look just like the guy described and
this is when you're playing as a
character who's like six feet tall
menacing with an eye patch and he's like
no that's that's how I described my fake
boyfriend to my dad okay and so you have
to like go sit down to dinner with her
father and sort of like she's like by
the way he's very strict he's very picky
and you have to like give him the right
answers to make sure that you're not
like blowing her cover mm-hmm and but
like it's the ending isn't just like oh
you convince the data you didn't I won't
spoil it but there's a wrinkle that that
shirt that shows up and that sort of
thing is present in all these little
side stories at first it seems like just
an excuse to introduce something stupid
and silly but but finds a way to just
like endear itself to you a little bit
more by making it about like an
unexpected little twist so you've been
telling me that you don't actually kill
many people in this game which is
striking because I just watched him beat
the [ __ ] out of someone with a bicycle
and a giant urn yeah I mean you will
grind people facing the pavement you
will you know slam them skull first and
we grant like you just do all sorts of
things that should easily kill somebody
but that's sort of you know that combat
falls into the more
comedic side of the game than it does
the serious story part and I say serious
because the story really does take
itself seriously it does not goof around
at all in no way shape or form the same
way the rest of the game does yeah so
it's just awesome little like palate
cleanser in this nice balance and the
game is also really accessible in terms
of figuring out okay what's my next
destination for the story you always
know so at any time you can just say
look I'm going to screw around for a
minute and you want get back to the
story you can do it immediately so it's
like a it's a buffet of these various
things that you can just easily get to
enjoy for what they are and you think
that it would spoil the other half
because they're so different but it
works in concert because you don't
really have to do the funny stuff if you
don't want to it's there just for you to
enjoy and this guy's about to cut his
pinkie off that's hilarious these guys
watch so what's really interesting is
that you look at these character models
some of them like this guy's based on a
real world actor but anyway these
characters all primary characters in the
game whether they're based off a real
world character or not look pretty good
but all npcs look like crap like look
like uh Perez ps2 models with new
texturing outside of cutscenes outside
of cutscenes but but you know yeah and
it's it's kind of jarring to an extent
but again this game it's over world it's
not huge but it's got a lot of depth to
it there are there are hundreds side
stories to follow probably a dozen
different mini games which includes
baseball karaoke bowling darts disco
dancing softcore porn betting on
gorillas and they're colliding like yeah
I know okay there's it's it's a game
that doesn't really like you know hide
its roots as being rooted in late 80s
Japan and it's about Yakuza which do you
know it's not really that great towards
women so you have to be you know you
kind of have to roll your eyes a little
bit and get over that fact doesn't make
it right it just sort of makes it one of
those things depending on your taste
share them whether it's authentic or not
for the time period yeah I mean it's
what it worth I mean I get that it still
made me uncomfortable at times yay I'm
not approved by any measure but there's
still some themes where it's just like
goddamn like they really are treating
women [ __ ] yeah so but you know what
that's it's a really small part of the
game so I don't want to harp on that for
too long
important to consider if those things
are important you you might have
mentioned this already but I kind of got
distracted by the game in general being
it right now at the softcore porn and
the this thumping head but it's the
aquas of zero because it's prequel to
the series correct for the first game
presumably yeah and there are let's see
six main story games there is Jacques
Dead Souls and then so the remake of the
first game yeah because at kiawah me is
coming out this summer and then we're
getting yuccas of six down the road so
that fixes the next sequel coming up yes
so in order to play the let's see would
be two three four and five you need a
ps2 and ps3 those games are only
available in those platforms yes its way
it's weird that there's what there's
going to be a seat of sixth game plus
zero plus the remake mmm seem like a
huge series obviously I've played
denticles and if you got spin-off like
Dead Souls and distal is like nothing
like the charters right way I mean
there's also a one set in feudal Japan
yeah unfortunately we're not going to
get in the West unless things yeah cos 0
is selling out on amazon in most
countries really so this is I think the
first one where people are kind of
willing to jump in so who knows we might
get that eventually maybe zeg of Japan
because honestly like western sales
really do dictate a lot of what happens
in Japan in terms of game development
now yeah so who knows maybe the success
of 0 the presume success will lead to
more these games being remade or being
imported or localized yeah it's also
I've again dead souls of the first night
played and only but 0 is kind of
tempting just because of everything I'm
seeing and hearing dude and I put like
50 to 60 hours in this game and my
completion percentage was sixteen
percent there is so much to do that if
you if you really enjoy this I mean
it'll last you 100 hours if not more
yeah that sounds awesome Aaron have you
played a yak is a game before my
experience of Yakuza is a Cajun I look
over my shoulder and see really weird
[ __ ] going on on Peters monitor and I'm
like he must be playing Yakuza again
this year it's that time of year
whenever it cuts to a kleenex box i know
it's peter playing Yakuza Pete got one
on hand and keep a small in my pocket
kleenex box does
little pocket tissue thing oh nice
that's actually a thing you get in the
gate I won't go into it no matter your
lunch breaks now you collect eyes
there's a copy you meet who likes to
frisk you and he wants to make sure that
you don't have any contraband on you and
there's people who are constantly
handing out free samples like they kind
of do in cities in Japan and so you can
get pocket tissues ad infinitum then you
can just essentially use those two til
show the cop that you're a good person
gotcha no weapons no drugs well you're a
full review is up on gamespot now and
give it an eight out of ten you'd like
to seem a lot do you know what are some
of the drawbacks everyone's very
inconsistent graphics combat that does
grow a little bit repetitive despite the
creativity that you can have with the
takedown moves that's kind of it you
know like it it does a really good job
at most everything else Rodrigo guignol
may live in the YouTube chat is also
pretty astounded that you only completed
sixteen percent after that much time I
know I mean I finished the story that
sixteen percent includes the story plus
all side content so I did I think 30
side stories and played about 10 hours
or so of like the mini games plus side
story stuff here's already game right
here with a guy in tighty whities in an
alleyway oh yeah so this is walking
erection that is his name yes you meet
him oh you're serious I'm serious that
was a joke on my part you media haha and
he's in the subtitle in the subtitle
walking erection says so basically you
meet this guy he's like hey I just saw
that you were in this club last night so
you must like paper I'd lose he's like
trust me if you ever need to find me
need some advice on how to get off I'm
everywhere he talks about how often he
gets off like yeah why didn't mr. libido
now it keeps changing his name I think
it's based on the context of what you
learn about the character moment a
moment what yep arently his will be
though I was like his pride because he
can get off like six times a day so he
just does never satisfied he just goes
to fit ups and gets off all that yeah
awesome yeah that's the life good for
him man that's why I always smile always
got a six-pack and he's isn't working
rushing through his body almost at all
times among other things alright sweet
enough of that yeah go play that game
too sounds like I want to now not
because of the walking direction or the
softcore porn I want to walk for the
melodrama and this serious thing
make me sound like an intelligent human
being a not actually a very low brow
person that so thrown off yes here take
over eps review it's on danse watch calm
did you notice how the viewercount jump
you almost doubled mr. Hornet we found
out the screams a secret algorithm has a
secret getting people in our stream we
just put softcore porn on seriously CBS
is going to like rappel into this room
and take us out alright anyways since
third time go read that review it's good
the game sounds awesome I'm looking
forward to playing
[Music]